>> KOLEDA: Hi, I'm Eric Koleda with the Google
Developer Relations team. This screencast
will show you how to get started with the
AdWords API PHP Client Library. The library
requires PHP version 5.2 and the extensions
SoapClient, OpenSSL, and cURL. The first thing
we need to do is download the library. The
best way to find it is by going to the AdWords
API documentation at code.google.com/apis/adwords.
From here, click on Docs, Libraries & Samples,
and PHP Client Library. This is the main project
page of the AdWords API PHP Client Library.
On the right-hand side of the pages, a convenient
link to download the latest version. Once
the download is complete, extract it to a
folder of your choice. Before you can start
using the library, you must set the Authentication
Information. Browse to Source, Google, API,
Ads, AdWords, and open the file auth.ini.
When testing a new library, it's best to use
a SandBox account. More information on the
SandBox environment is available in the screen
cast, Intro to the AdWords API SandBox. Entering
your SandBox credentials, starting with the
email and password of your Google account,
enter a user agent that identifies your application.
The application token itself is ignored in
the SandBox. And enter a developer token which
is your email address plus, plus the currency
code. Finally, set the client ID to the email
of one the automatically generated client
accounts, and save the changes to the file.
Since we are using the sandbox environment,
you must also set the default server in settings.ini.
For the Sandbox, this is adwords-sandbox.google.com.
You are now ready to make a request with the
library. The examples folder contains a subfolder
for every version of the API that the client
library supports. To start, we'll open a command
prompt, and browse to the examples folder.
The first example we'll run is GetAllCampaigns.php.
Since this is a new sandbox account, there
will not be any existing campaigns. To create
some campaigns, we'll run AddCampaign.php.
This example added a new campaign to the account,
and if we rerun GetAllCampaigns.php, we can
see the return of the results. Now, let's
create a new example to pause a campaign.
Create a new file called PauseCampaign.php,
and open the text editor. The first thing
we need to do is include the Adwordsphp library.
One way to do this is to set the include path
to contain the source code for the PHP client
library, and then require the AdWordsUser
class. You don't need to require each service
individually because they will be automatically
required by the AdWords user. Next, we'll
paste in the try catch loop to ensure that
any errors generated by the library will be
caught and displayed. Next, we'll create the
AdWords user object which will load the credentials
from the auth.ini set earlier and then enable
logging. The campaign service can be fetched
from the AdWords user using the kit campaign
service method. We'll need to set the campaign
ID for the campaign we wished to modify. We
go back to the command prompt, we can pull
the ID from the previous example.
Next, we'll create the updated campaign object
setting the ID to the ID of the existing campaign
and changing the status to paused. Now that
we've created the updated campaign object,
we can create the operation that will perform
the change. We'll set the operand to the campaign
we just created and the operator to set which
will perform an update. Finally, we'll create
an array of operations containing only this
one operation. We're now ready to make the
API call which is done by calling the campaign
service method mutate passing in the array
of operations. Finally, we'll loop over the
results displaying the name, ID, and status
of each of the campaigns that were changed.
We'll save this example, go back to our command
prompt, and run the example.
Now we can see there are campaigns where it's
updated and has a status pause. Updates to
the library will be announced on a project's
homepage. The AdWords API Blog will contain
the information about new services being launched.
If you have any questions about using the
API, you can post them to the forum. Finally,
if you find any bugs in the PHP client library,
click the Issue in the Issue tracker. Thank
you for your time and then enjoy using the
client library.